Kove in nineteen the deadly virus which
is spread to every continent on the
globe except Antarctica so how could
coronavirus start to affect you a
science correspondent Thomas More is
here alongside an expert panel of guests
to answer your questions after noon we
have retail analyst Kate Hardcastle
senior clinical lecturer at the
University of Exeter dr. Barrett pan
carnea and Simon called their travel
editor of the independent we'll be
seeing them shortly I want to talk to
Thomas at first though Thomas lots of
people getting in touch with their
questions let's first talk about the
World Health Organization earlier on
saying the word pandemic is not helpful
and it's likely to inflame the situation
but we heard the health secretary
earlier on that Hancock in the House of
Commons giving us update using the P
word a lot the EU their processes
they're calling it a pandemic as well
Paul con you on Twitter asks has the
time not come for the w-h-o to classify
coronavirus as a pandemic given how
we've seen it spread in the last 24
hours or so well certainly some doctors
I've spoken to have called this a
pandemic in all but name it clearly has
a dictionary definition it is global
spread of a severe infectious disease
and many people would say we've reached
that point now the World Health
Organization is very cautious about
calling it a pandemic because they got
into a lot of trouble back in 2009 with
the swine flu pandemic that it that a
lot of countries were waiting for the
call which didn't come for a long time
and therefore delayed action and so on
this time around they're not going to
get into that hot water what they're
saying is that each country should be
able to make a risk judgment for
themselves on how bad the outbreak is in
their country and take the appropriate
action there and it's interesting a lot
of people getting in touch saying you
know the message from the health
secretary matt hancock essentially was
keep calm and carry on when he spoke to
comments this afternoon and the advice
being drummed into people is if you're
in doubt call NHS one-one-one and self
isolate what does self isolating mean
it's a really good good question I mean
the moment the test is is a swab of the
throat of mucus and that is looking for
genetic material from the virus it will
identify people who've got an active
infection if that result then comes back
as positive
you'll be asked to stay at home for 14
days that is the the period that you are
thought to be in infectious for and that
essentially will mean that you do not go
out you don't go to work you don't take
public transport you don't pop to the
shops you can though still have
deliveries made to your home so friends
and relatives can do your shopping for
you you can still get somebody to bring
a takeaway around those kind of things
can still go on but you should be
minimizing contact with other people
because the longer you spend surrounded
by other people the greater the chance
they will be passing the virus on okay
Thomas let's bring in our panel that I
mentioned before we got an expert in
travel an expert in business and retail
and a public health expert as well and
simonkal there our travel expert I'll
come to you first we've just heard about
that Six Nations rugby game in Dublin
being called off so people probably
going to travel to Dublin will think
twice I've got a question here from
Nicola beverage on Twitter she says I'm
going on a cruise on the 6th of March I
fly via Edinburgh Heathrow Rio in Brazil
Brazil of course I'm confirming its
first case then I get to Tenerife Lisbon
Cadiz I mean it sounds like an
incredible cruise
she says should I cancel because she's
effectively hitting every hot spot here
she says though if I didn't cancel I
lose around 4 grand
of course she shouldn't cancel what a
wonderful opportunity but I would be so
careful you are going through the
busiest airport in Europe London
Heathrow you'll be changing planes there
and airports are the places that I
reckon present the biggest biohazard
it's a microbiological party everybody
from around the world converges with
their own personal germs and they all
get mixed up particularly in the
security area at airports be really
careful in terms of not getting too
close to people I know that's difficult
when you're in in queues and certainly
after the security search particularly
if you've been handling the tray that
you put were your liquids and your phone
in go and have a good I'll wash and with
proper soap and water because that's
probably the most the biggest danger
you're going to encounter in your entire
wonderful holiday and then you know just
things like keeping a distance from
anybody who looks ill which all do
wakers you're a sensible person and if
you can pay for food and drink with
contactless rather than handling cash
but apart from that it sounds a great
trip and I must pick you up you said hot
spots well yeah there's some some
unfortunate cases in Tenerife but the
chances of any of us going to places
where there are cases and actually being
in proximity with people who've got the
virus long enough to catch it are
thankfully extremely low and even if you
do pick it up I would say the biggest
danger for the vast majority of people
leaving aside the cohort of over 70s and
people with unfortunately weakened
immune systems the biggest danger is
that you bring it back and you spread it
that's that's what worries me about it
not actually I'm having the nasty but
for most people not not fatal virus
noting sagely along there because we
keep hearing about NHS one one while we
keep hearing about self-isolation but
personal hygiene as well we can't
emphasize that enough Thank You Simon
and Nicola beverages just tweeted me a
few minutes ago Oh Kate this could own
oh this is Hannah I beg your pardon
Hannah Kell so this one's for you Kate
and it's about employers duty of care
Hannah says I'm a university student
doing a clinical placement at a large
hospital for 40 weeks this year one of
my rights in terms of going to a
placement during a pandemic and what is
my employers duty of care towards me
well I think the important note is that
we've got information through that many
people our beam acetate is 14-day
isolation period and there's certainly
some questions about where people stand
it's very important to speak to your
employer and understand your contractual
rights when it comes to things like this
because unless you're actually sick with
an illness you might not get the sick
pain you think you're due and you have
to speak to them many big businesses
will be able to make the decision that
they're going to treat the welfare of
their staff but at the office are at
work a place of work and at home
equally as well and they will probably
cover that 14-day period however it's
not always the case so important to
check that detail also work with your
organisation to see what information
they need from you how often they need
you to update them speak to them
constantly look out
noticeboards information briefings and
another quick point to mention as well
is actually if you can work if you are
in an isolated period of 14 days if you
can work with your organization perhaps
do some work from home for them I'll
look to be actually responsibly trying
to deliver on your work still whilst
you're off work and not always possible
where we've got rules that completely
reliant on placement of your activities
but it's important to speak to employer
all the way through and dr. pan Carney
I've got a question for you a lot of
people very concerned about a leaked UK
government document talking about a
reasonable worst-case scenario when it
comes to coronavirus a lot of people
talking about this on social media
perhaps you can shed some light on it it
says in this reasonable worst-case
scenario 80 percent of British citizens
could be infected with the coronavirus
cave in 19 and around 500,000 would die
can you put that into perspective for us
is there some truth in that happy to do
so I haven't looked at this legal
document but thinking empirically and
from first principles so if I was given
that scenario my answer is very
straightforward it's easy to answer so
this is a new virus and because it is a
new virus we expect people to get
infected that's nothing new that's not a
big deal I want to reassure our
listeners which is this and you heard it
before from our other commentator that
most people who get infected will get
better and most people will suffer a
mild illness only a very few numbers
will actually need to see a doctor and
fewer still go to hospital and fewer
still go to I to you now when we talk
about what is a technical term called
case fatality right it means off those
people who become ill how many go on to
die and when you are talking about large
percentages large numbers and then a
small percent of a very large number
obviously is it sounds alarming that
goodness me are so many people going to
die but if you put it into perspective
with the seasonal influenza infection a
lot of people die every year from
seasonal influenza infection which by
the way is preventable so
we need to have that perspective and
when you start thinking about large
numbers it's unnecessarily worrying and
I would want our listeners not to be dr.
can I just didn't ask you a question
because we're seeing here a lot of
effort being taken globally now driven
by the World Health Organization to try
and contain this virus if flu is a much
bigger problem every year we let that go
by we don't take this extreme action so
is this something we're not being told
about this cove in nineteen outbreak no
no no why would we want to lie and why
would we want to not tell you the truth
my University of Exeter has never
censored me and I I don't have a brief
off go here go there or don't go there
so let me share with our listeners what
I would like to share with anyone which
is the reason why everyone is excited
and concerned about it is because this
is a new virus this has emerged in China
and is now spreading to cause illness
but and the excitement in and and and
and concerns are because it is new it's
brand new and because it's brand new we
don't know a lot about it to put it in
context and give a balancing act for you
I would say the corona virus appears to
be a little bit worse than the seasonal
influenza virus but it's only a little
bit more worse than the seasonal
influenza virus it is not something
completely different which is going to
be a shock to the system we don't see
that evidence so I hope I can give that
reassuring messages or our listeners
side of us sorry assignment another
question for you and it's interesting
many people getting in touch saying look
I'm looking at what's going on I've
planned a holiday say to Tenerife or
Italy and even though the risk might be
low in the government is saying you can
still travel to those areas I just don't
want to go so what are their rights well
you have none effectively I mean there's
a slight there's a few odd cases so for
instance if you were going to the rugby
in Dublin and you booked a package that
included match tickets and it was clear
that you were going there for the
purposes of seeing a rugby match same
applies for rum
England in Rome then you will be able to
claim a full refund if the match that
doesn't go ahead but for everybody else
and I've talked to lots and lots of
people I've never known quite such
concern about this going to Florence
going to Venice going to Milan
how lovely skiing in the Italian Alps
absolutely great the travel industry's
attitude is we're still flying your
holiday still exists there's no foreign
office water you gets going this
inclination to travel doesn't cut it
doesn't mean anything
you'll lose most of all of your money
most all of your money and your travel
ensuring that sounds really harsh and
I'm sorry about that but that is the
attitude the only flexibility I've seen
so far is British Airways is saying if
you're booked to go to northern Italy in
the next week or so you can postpone but
only till the end of March and a lot of
people won't be happy with that and of
course if you've got flights car rental
skiing butch on top of that then that's
not going to help either so it's a very
blunt you know that the holiday is going
ahead if you don't want to tough luck
I'm sorry
and yes tough luck but you know sound
advice those are the facts for people to
get their heads around and make those
decisions okay let's get back to retail
and what's going to be the knock-on
effect we're looking at are we looking
at people are asking shortages in
British shops because of the disruption
in China and perhaps potential price
rises as well I think it's really
important to set the scene when it comes
to China
I quite understandably a lot of people
just can't understand quite how much of
our products either come from China or
indeed have component parts that come
from China indeed it was 20 years ago
when I started working in the factories
there that only then could I understand
the size and scale now what's happening
the factories in China is a complete
shutdown and that includes 14 days end
of quarantine for workers to get back
many who actually live there so
production is hugely affected and to
also put some perspective on this the
retailer Walmart's one of the biggest in
the USA has 25 percent of its products
that come from China we already have
heard there's profit warnings and
challenges and
they stops and shares have seen the
challenge as economists try and get to
grips with just how long this not an
effects going to happen so certainly
when it comes to the supply chain
reliant on component parts or products
in China though is probably going to be
some shortages because that shipping
takes 8 to 10 weeks to get to the UK if
it's on the Seas short or if it's by air
also you've got to think about then the
prices that these organizations are
going to have to take into stock with
the fact that they're having to catch up
with what's been a very challenging
period
I don't think sarah-jane we've seen the
full effect yet because what happened
with the beginning of this outbreak is
it was actually at the same time there's
a Chinese New Year one of the only times
as production sources actually closed
down so be very aware also do start to
watch stock shortages things like panic
buying on anti back White's and
antibacterial liquids when it comes to
the economy generally and businesses yes
there's going to be a knock-on effect
and that's not just because of that
that's because this is an economy that's
already faced challenges of political
unrest things like brakes it coming into
it it's just not as robust as it could
have been and that means that another
thing that was unplanned for couldn't
even be speculated for is causing a lot
of headaches and challenges so
definitely be aware of your finances and
the implications dr. pan Konya are a lot
of concern about the fact that people
are saying many people can contract over
19 and be completely symptomless how
dangerous is that in the spread of this
because obviously if you haven't got any
symptoms you may not feel that you have
to self isolate and does that make this
a bigger problem than we currently know
about do you think we don't know a lot
about the new coronavirus range of us
sign symptoms infection pattern having
said that of course it is difficult it
is extremely difficult if you are
without symptoms and yet infected and
infectious it makes our lives very
difficult to contain it look on the
positive side thus far we are succeeding
in containing in the United Kingdom
second point if you are infected but
without symptoms that's telling you the
story straight away which
a lot of people will get infected and a
lot of people will be well even with the
infection and they will make a full
recovery so that's all so in a
roundabout way
a reassuring message that whilst my job
our job of containing it keeping it away
keeping the numbers down making sure
that our health services are not
overwhelmed with too many cases all
those things are very difficult but the
reassuring message for people are our
viewers is in most cases for most people
they will make a full recovery and most
people will not be very ill and tamas
it's interesting a lot of people getting
in touch saying you know they know about
NHS one one one self isolating but
they're saying if I'm worried how can I
get tested for covert 19 well you'd have
to fall into one of the categories that
you've been to one of the affected areas
that you've also showing these flu-like
symptoms that's when the NHS would swing
into action their last either asked you
to come down to one of these pods
outside hospitals where you can be
tested without infecting other people in
the waiting room or now we've heard
today from the health secretary that
they're going to start piloting home
testing so a team will come to your
house and do the test again so you're
not encountering other people on the way
and that is really what the NHS is
trying to do to limit this the spread of
the virus from people who might be
affected and Simon Jenny's going to
touch saying yeah if what if you've got
relatives in one of these quarantine
areas particularly in the quarantined
hotel in Tenerife what kind of
information are they getting what kind
of support should they be getting well
of course we've heard some stories
overnight of the people being without
food and drink in their hotel and I
imagine that the Spanish authorities are
dealing with that fairly quickly because
clearly that cannot continue as it is
there's so much anxiety and stress and
worry in and around that hotel but I
think your question actually is kind of
goes wider than that which is that
people are seeing that there are these
quarantine going on we saw of course the
Diamond Princess ship in
in Yokohama as well as the h10 hotel in
Costa a day hey in Tenerife and people's
alarm in certainly in terms of those
who've contacted me on social media is
now veering towards well look okay I
might might not can't act the virus on
but I'm really worried that I will be
kept in quarantine and I can't do that
because family depend on me I've got to
get back to run my business there's all
sorts of reasons why people simply
cannot afford to be delayed abroad
there's if you've got a holiday that of
course is something that you will be
taking into account and I must say I'd
be interesting to get a medical view on
this keeping people incarcerated on a
cruise ship or inside a hotel when
actually the people who very sadly have
had the virus that we know about have
been through airports going out to
restaurants enjoying excursions all
sorts of things
so to keep people who may be on the
seventeenth floor when the unfortunate
Italian doctor was on the sixth floor
I'm not sure how much use that will be
in restricting the spread of this and
most certainly it is causing a great
deal of worry and and I just what an
awful thing there you are in one of the
loveliest islands in the world and
you're stuck inside a hotel and this is
just coming from aralia Lupton and this
one will be for you doctor she says
what's the survivability of the virus on
services because we've seen a lot of
schools be deep cleaned if somebody's
been in there that's suspected to be
infected how long can this virus survive
on services reasonably good question to
ask and the answer would be it depends
on the humidity in other words the
moisture in the air so in dry warm hot
places where the virus may have landed
from nasal or mouth secretions it dries
out the de nature's and it becomes
ineffective so warm moist wet ish places
its survival period is longer and in dry
soft cushions
fabrics where it dries out a lot faster
it's not going to survive for long
that's all we've got time for that's our
expert panel answering your questions on
co vid 19 Kate Hardcastle dr. pan cornea
and Simon called Oh Anna cause Thomas
Moore thank you very much